hello everyone we are pleased to had
join us for decart Cardinal Health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast Shiga toxin-producing e.coli
what you need to know now I am Bob
Woodard of lab routes and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes and
sponsored by alaria alaria delivers
reliable and actionable information
through rapid diagnostic tests resulting
in better clinical and economic health
care outcomes globally for more
information please visit Larry comm we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this presentation has
been approved for continuing education
credits please click on the C button at
the bottom left corner of the auditorium
this will direct you to the necessary
site and form needed to receive your
credits this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to
submit answers during the event you can
submit questions by typing them into the
Q&A window which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left hand corner of the
presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon at the lower right
hand corner of the screen window if you
have any technical problems during the
webcast please click on the support
button located at the upper right hand
corner of the presentation window you
can also submit any problems you may be
having using the Q&A box following this
presentation head over to the community
of learning in the lab exchange Lobby to
have the opportunity to engage in a live
chat and have more of your questions
answered on the spot about Shiga
toxin-producing e.coli what you need to
know now I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Norman or dr. Moore
is the director of scientific affairs
for Allari he received his bachelor's
degree in biology and philosophy from
Dartmouth College and his PhD in
microbiology from the University of New
Hampshire dr. Moore developed the first
ever rap
for Legionella and streptococcus Newman
I both of which are now recommended by
the infectious disease Society of
America for use in severe pneumonia
cases dr. Moore has multiple patents
publications and presentations and now
serves as the director of scientific
affairs for infectious diseases he has
served on multiple national institute of
allergy and infectious disease grant
committees the College of American
Pathologists and ERDs Institute
guideline Committee for point of care
infectious disease please join me in
welcoming dr. Moore to the day's event I
will now turn the presentation over to
him well thank you all very much so with
that introduction I'd like to get right
into it and again feel free to ask any
questions at the end we will be talking
about sugar toxin today now I give a
fair amount of lectures and one of the
great driving threats one of the things
that really links all of Diagnostics
together when you're talking about
infectious disease is what it means to
the world to the world when you think
about the great threats to humankind
certainly things like terrorism and
nuclear weapons come to mind but when
you talk to people out there and all the
leaders if you go down to the CDC and
you say what keeps you awake at night
it's basically antibiotic resistance we
have at this point condition so many of
our doctors to give out big
broad-spectrum antibiotics every time
somebody comes in with a sickness that
we have and it's no surprise to anybody
here significant amounts of resistance
in the hospitals today so at this point
if you screened everybody right now
roughly 10% of people have staff poison
arrows and actually one to two percent
of people in the community have
methicillin-resistant staphylococcus in
their nose right now so it's something
that's very significant and it's going
up not only hospital-acquired but
community-acquired as well so and I give
a lot when I give a lot of microbiology
talks it's I start with quite often with
an interesting quote as a microbiologist
this is my favorite quote
in 1970 which isn't too long ago for a
lot of us the Surgeon General said the
United States is ready to close the book
on infectious disease is a major health
threat now back in 1970 infectious
diseases really weren't even in the top
10 killers and so when you look at
what's happened you know you go to 1995
and it's the number three killer only
behind heart disease and cancer and of
course today it's a critical critical
concern in a lot of ways we've gone
backwards you know so everybody thinks
as medicine always improving but we have
taken that wonderful treasure of
antibiotics and at this point so abused
it that we are now getting infections
that we we can't quite often control we
can now have cases where you know a
child comes in with a simple otitis
media the first round of antibiotics
doesn't work the second round
antibiotics doesn't work they can become
septic and sometimes die now there are
other issues too with vaccinations which
I want to get into but suffice it to say
right now we are in some ways worse off
than we were decades ago and again when
we talk about these antibiotics what is
amazing is the amount of overuse when
you look at these places you know if you
go into a hospital right now one in
every three patients is going to receive
act usually two or more antibiotics and
when you look at all the antibiotics
given to these patients about seventy
five percent are either unnecessary or
redundant so again we have that mental
feeling of in some ways no harm no foul
we're just because it might be a
bacterial infection less thorough as
many antibiotics edit as possible and
that leads to all these other
complications and even with just the
amount of upper respiratory illnesses
we're prescribing tens of millions of
antibiotics when we really don't need
that not only is there a medical cost
but there's a financial cost when you
look at what's happening with a lot of
the medical systems right now they're
going to be encouraged the burdened of
any hospital acquired infections so you
know if you're in a hospital and you're
Mercer rate is fine if you're C
difficile rate is high
and the patient gets that infection
there is going to dramatically increase
lengths of stay as well as hurt that
particular patient so you look at beyond
that is about a billion dollars spent
unnecessarily on these antibiotics and
so when you look at the total cost to
society right now we're talking about
twenty billion dollars in healthcare
costs about thirty five billion in
societal cost societal costs are going
to be missing work missing school and
that's going to account for about eight
million additional Hospital days when
you look when you really think about
Diagnostics when you think about disease
if you know more specifically what is
causing that disease you really open up
a lot of options to have budded better
directed therapy and once you have
better directed therapy you do have
better outcomes and so this is I don't
have too many quotes I think this is my
last quote but it's one that I think
really kind of makes people stop and
think you know post-antibiotic era means
in effect an end to modern medicine as
we know it things as common as strep
throat or a child scratch knee could
once again kill and so I know that
sounds dramatic but we're at a point
where the things can get quite dramatic
and I know that there's pressure on
doctors I know that there is pressure to
prescribe antibiotics when a parent
comes in with with a sick child they
want to be treated even if it's a
influenza and antibiotics that do no
good whatsoever what we need to do is a
medical community and it's not an easy
thing is really try to help educate the
entire community that there is actual
harm when you give antibiotics when
they're not necessary when we look at
things we are increasing the amount of
resistance that is significant and if I
talk to more parental groups there are
other issues as well if I give an
antibiotic it's not only killing the
clinical bad bacteria it's it's actually
creating resistance and the good
bacteria as well so if I keep giving
antibiotics to children what can happen
is your commensal your normal healthy
bacteria will become resistant and then
when you get a subsequent pathogen they
can actually share that genetic
information so that you can have a
reservoir of resistance that can
actually go to the pathogen afterwards
so there is harm by giving antibiotics
over and over again so it really - a lot
of these people you're taking that
antibiotic as a choice away because you
don't have that residual layer of
resistance and even beyond that they're
now linking a lot of childhood obesity
to antibiotics and when you think about
it you you've got a normal healthy gut
flora and if you start destroying that
normal healthy gut flora and you're not
able to process you know foods as well
it can lead to obesity it's also
antibiotics does lead to things like
yeast infections as well so when you put
all that together we are trying to go
more toward a lot of antibiotic
stewardship where we're really trying to
you know there are wonderful guidelines
out there you know groups like the
infectious disease Society of America
look at every article published and put
out these guidelines every few years and
they've got their best practices so
looking toward what those guidelines say
who you should be testing for what in
how that therapy should be given is
really quite helpful so when you've got
those guidelines this tea stewardship
committees can look make sure that the
optimal outcomes are given by the right
antibiotics and again if you give the
right antibiotic you have other less
issues I give a lot of c.difficile
lectures and I can talk an entire hour
on how to clean a room from C difficile
spores C C difficile spores are very
very Hardy but then the question comes
in if you are decolonizing every patient
that walks in by giving them these
broad-spectrum antibiotics so your
entire patient population is now
susceptible to C difficile it's really
hard to control them so if you're
talking about C difficile and you're
worried and you're spending tons of
money on hand sent into the hand and
sanitization and cleaners etc if we
don't change our prescribing practices
and everything is linked together in
some ways it's a waste of money so when
you put that stewardship can group
together you can again preserve
those antibiotics when you do need an
and then you actually do reduce costs
and I'll say one more thing on this
before going to C difficile
I mean before going to sugar toxin and
that is a lot of people think that these
broad-spectrum antibiotics are the most
effective killers and they're not when
you think of something like vancomycin
there is significant kidney damage and
it is not going to get you out of the
hospital any earlier and quite often it
can get you out later if something like
streptococcus pneumoniae is the pathogen
and it's susceptible to penicillin
penicillin is more effective has less
cost and will decrease the length of
stay so knowing what pathogen you're
dealing with does help and so basically
I won't spend too much time on but just
to say when you put a committee together
you really want to include a lot of
different areas of that hospital so when
we now start talking about Diagnostics
it is becoming more and more important
to really understand do the testing so
you can better target what that pathogen
is and treat accordingly that's going to
have a lot of benefits from reducing the
antibiotic overuse that shorten that
time to an appropriate therapy again we
talked about providing targeted
treatment and not having those broad
specters because we really do need to
hold on to those broad spectrum
antibiotics for them we truly do need
them for many years
a lot of the pharmaceutical companies
realized that there were a lot more
profitable drugs out there you know
unfortunately things like there just are
more thing you know things that can be
getting far more money so what they did
was they looked at their pipeline and
they said okay let's not spend as much
time on antibiotics and so when they
spent last time when antibiotics had
more time on things like viagra you know
viagra is something that that people
love taking over and over again so it
was a highly highly profitable drug with
something like antibiotics if doctors
abused it it is going to become less
effective and therefore it's got a
shorter shelf life now they have turned
on the pipeline for new antibiotics but
we are still potentially about 10 years
away and because of that we really have
to save what we have right now for when
we truly need it so when we talk about
gastrointestinal disease one of the big
issues is very very difficult to
diagnose on symptoms alone these
symptoms are so ubiquitous so even that
is very very hard to understand really
what the pathogen is and there are
actually hundreds of potential causes
and quite often when you have that
diarrhea it does lead to this treatment
and again we do worry that some of these
treatments may actually hurt the patient
so again knowing the pathogen is better
as an example of hurting that patient
one of the things that we've seen right
now is things like C difficile a lot of
people that are healthy can carry C
difficile and what can happen is if they
take an antibiotic for respiratory
disease for example antibiotics can
cause diarrhea when they cause diarrhea
if we then find C difficile we couldn't
potentially then give them another
antibiotic too then you know hopefully
thinking that we're removing this the C
difficile where D colonized in that
patient and potentially giving them now
making them susceptible to a subsequent
infection with c diff so it gets very
very confusing so Diagnostics really do
help try to delineate exactly what they
have as a general issue diarrhea kills
about 1.5 to 2.5 million children a year
so it's a very very significant
worldwide disease and in certain parts
of the world we're talking about people
getting cases of diarrhea 5 to 18 times
every single year now luckily in the
United States we have a bit more better
sanitation so what we're seeing in the
u.s. right now is adults tending to get
one acute case per year young children
tending to get about two cases per year
so that all leads to about a quarter
billion cases right now in the United
States each year a lot of the concern of
those cases of the children
under five and that rolls into a lot of
other complications where you're talking
about tens of millions of physician
consultations certainly with parents
they have a lot of concerns when when
the child is young and so they are
bringing them in for a lot of diarrhea
that's going to lead to almost 2 million
cases of hospitalizations about 3,100
deaths and when you look at it all in
total about 25 billion to the healthcare
community right now when we look at
foodborne illnesses which can often
quite often come with gastrointestinal
illness we're talking about 76 million
cases $325 hospitalizations and about
5,000 deaths so I put up a picture of
the IDSA guidelines just to kind of show
that you don't have to test everybody
for diarrhea for absolutely everything
when they've got a hospital-acquired
quite often you do link to C difficile
when they're coming in from the
community that's when you start looking
at things like Salmonella Shigella can't
be the e.coli o157 we are getting more C
difficile coming in from the community
but that's another concern another topic
and if they've got that persistent
diarrhea if they've been traveling if
they've been hiking quite often you then
start thinking of things like Giardia
and Cryptosporidium now I'm going to not
going to go through all the ideological
agents for diarrhea but just to say
there are many causes obviously with the
viral infections and antibiotic that so
ever one of the big ones out there is
norovirus so again if you've got an
outbreak in the community quite often it
can be due to that I actually had the
unfortunate time that the last time I
got a normal virus infection I was
actually at a conference at the National
Institute of Health so I was actually
food poisoned at NIH which is kind of an
interesting story to have when you look
at those bacterial infections again we
talked about camera can't blow bacteria
Salmonella etc we've also got the
parasites but let's start diving now
into a cola and then more specifically
sugar toxin-producing e.coli ecoli is
something that is ubiquitous in the gut
it's
it's in every person's gut right now and
around actually 10% of your fecal mass
is ecoli cells and if you break a party
coli cells that's what gives stool a lot
of the aroma that you know and love out
there so it is very common and it's okay
to have e.coli the issue is quite often
if you put bacteria in the wrong area of
the body that's when they can become a
problem yes there are particular types
of e.coli that can cause diarrhea but
again if they're in the wrong place they
can cause urinary tract infections
respiratory illnesses and even things
like pneumonia and we do use a co-op or
many other things when you're looking
for a B coli that tends to be the big
one that we use for a lot of our genetic
work we even use it for monitoring
things like water quality so if you're
out in the community and you hear things
like there's a high fever coliform what
that means is you are getting bacteria
that are normally present in a
warm-blooded animal it's in the water
and therefore it serves as a monitor
that if there are things like e.coli
then there can be any other enteric
pathogen as well and that can get into
the water by many ways you know farm
irrigation runoff if you're out in the
you know farming area and you've got a
septic system in a septic system is
leaking that can go right to the well so
there's lots of ways to get a coli out
there when we talk specifically about
eco lie sugar toxin-producing it's got a
few different names out there so if
you're out there and you hear things
like an or hemorrhage a coli varascite
of toxin ecoli basically it's all the
same thing it produces a toxin called
sugar toxin it actually is identical to
the toxin produced by Shigella what had
happened was at some point in
evolutionary history Shigella was there
and some of the e.coli picked up this
toxin and it is basically molecule for
molecule the same one out there now the
big one that we all have heard about is
a coli o157 h7 this is the one that had
the outbreak in the jack-in-the-box food
chain this is the one that
a lot of outbreaks where you have to
bring the meat back in that's the one
where usually the most concerned about
however it is noted that there are a lot
of other eco lies that also have that
sheet of toxin producing on a gene
therefore just looking for e.coli o157
is not going to be able to identify
everybody with this particular illness
so as far as that sugar toxin basically
comes in two main groups one and two I
won't spend too much time on that
but basically what it does is it at our
talks that does inhibit protein
synthesis and there are other
complications which we'll get into
things like hemolytic uremic syndrome
couple of the things about sugar
toxin-producing e.coli it doesn't sound
important but it is quite important is
that it is actually quite acid too
tolerant and the reason why that's
important is because quite often if you
ingest something a bacteria your gut
your the hydrochloric acid in your
stomach is something that's quite often
able to deactivate it with e.coli o157
it can survive you know your stomach
acid much more readily and therefore
much more likely to give you disease
there's actually a lot of foods out
there that are also high in acid if you
know you've got things like Salmonella I
mean
salami or some of those type of meats
believe it or not these Ecola one57 have
been able to survive that and be part of
that now also when you're talking about
infectious disease quite often you need
a large amount of bacteria to actually
become sick you know one bacteria
doesn't make an illness one of the
unfortunate difficulties with e.coli
o157 is it is one of those low dose
infections you don't need that many
cells to actually cause disease and the
third thing i missed is that it is
actually a bit more common in the summer
months and it's more common in the
summer months because quite often you
get things like outdoor activities like
swimming and barbecues and all of those
things have an ability to spread it
which we'll see in the next few slides
so when you talk about these symptoms
they do bury person-to-person so what
can happen is if a whole family is
infected quite often it can be
subclinical so there's going to be
people that really don't never know it
you know they get it they get over it
they don't even have any symptoms
however as part of the main symptoms if
you do have a bigger case a diarrhea
obviously is the bigger one it tends to
be potentially bloody now blood is still
is is fairly indicative that is a
concern people should go right to the
hospital when they have blood in the
stool unfortunately people don't you
know if the blood is a bit older you
know but the color can darken
unfortunate with a lot of kids they
actually get embarrassed when they see
blood the stool and don't tell their
parents so don't look just that hasit
blood in the stool to really have this
concern beyond that it's severe stomach
cramping vomiting some of these people
do have a fever as well if as a general
rule this does resolve on its own around
five to seven days unfortunately there
are some complications to sheikha
toxin-producing e.coli around five to
ten percent I get a thing that we
mentioned earlier called hemolytic
uremic syndrome so basically the
symptoms of this again we talked about
the bloody diarrhea they're not able to
urinate these people are quite tired and
you actually see the loss of that pink
color in their cheeks and on the inside
of their lower eyelid and I know that
sounds a little bit odd but what's
happening here is the kidneys actually
may stop working and that's the biggest
complication of hemolytic uremic
syndrome so some of these people do
recover but some of them unfortunately
do suffer permanent damage and it is
potentially life-threatening for
especially children under five so what's
the whole mechanism in all this
basically you have this toxin it's going
to cause the blood cells to misshapen
and these blood cells will actually claw
these tiny vesicles in the kidneys and
once that happens in the filtration by
the kidneys does become blocked the
kidney starts shutting down so again the
biggest problem out there with Nicole or
Owen prior seven really more often than
not is these kids because
of hemolytic uremic syndrome how was it
however there are other things out there
as well there's a thing called
thrombotic thrombocytopenic purpura and
again what's happening out there is
these toxins will stop changing the
shapes the red blood cells you're gonna
have clots start forming all over in
blood vessels and that is going to have
some impairment and that oxygen is start
is starting to not get to the organs you
know brain heart kidneys but one other
other thing is all these platelets
because of this get used up and
therefore you can start getting a lot
more internal bleeding so you're
actually gonna be seeing spots under the
skin lots of cuts this particular
illness tends to be more likely in
adults now some people do confuse
incubation periods out there if you're
in a restaurant and you get sick later
that night people tend to blame the
restaurant but usually most of these
foodborne pathogens have an incubation
period this one tends to be three to
four days however if you look at all
literature it could be 1 to 10 and again
the symptoms vary over the time you may
start off with a stomachache - that mild
diarrhea and that does become more
significant as time rolls by if you are
worried about hemolytic syndrome that
usually happens about a week after the
initial symptom so you get diarrhea a
week later on is when we have that more
significant illness as far as the stats
go on this when you look at the Center
for Disease Control website which they
try to update as often as they can we're
talking about just on this alone about a
quarter million cases each year in the
United States and out of that
quarter-million cases that a coli o157
is responsible for a little more than a
third so the issue is if you're only
looking for e.coli o157 you're missing
almost two-thirds of those cases now
that's a fairly high number and you
would think with such a high number that
we would actually be seeing more cases
in hospitals right now and a lot of
places screen and don't see a high
number so why aren't they seeing well
you know a lot of people when they have
diarrhea do not seek medical attention
and it's something that quite often is
embarrassing for a lot of people and
quite often they think it can resolve on
their own
and point out that even with sugar toxin
and can result in their own and many of
them do so that's quite often why we
don't actually see them coming in there
are people that may not give that stool
sample so it's something and
unfortunately like a sweet upset but you
can SPM sample fairly readily stool
samples don't come in as often and
unfortunately there are many
laboratories that are actually not able
to equipped to be testing stools as well
they have to quite often have to send it
off to a reference laboratory but one of
the big issues is we do want to diagnose
it soon because this is something where
you can be infecting other people so
again we mentioned that these do produce
toxins they do go away with symptoms
however we do find individuals that the
symptoms actually may resolve but they
can still have sugar toxin e.coli perd
in their gut producing and at that point
they can be potentially infecting other
people so these are the people that if
they're working in a daycare or cooking
they may have no symptoms but if they've
got this they and they don't wash your
hands appropriately after going to the
bathroom again with these small amounts
of e.coli that can produce disease they
can be significant vectors so if you've
had a sugar toxin e.coli infection it's
important to keep washing your hands for
a much longer time afterwards so I kind
of want to mention a few be fairly more
recent outbreaks in the last few years
first off just just to kind of explain
how this gets transmitted there's
multiple ways the big one that we quite
often know about is that people are out
we talked about their hand-washing when
you're out there and you've dealt with a
patient you really want to be able to
wash your hands and the general rule
right now is sing happy birthday to
yourself twice hand-washing is very very
effective at a lot of pathogens even
things like C difficile when you're out
there and you're washing your hands soap
and water does not kill C difficile
spores but what it does is that makes
them mobile and when it makes the mobile
you're able
rinse them away so wash your hands is
always a good thing obviously beyond
just the direct stool from one person to
another you could be getting things like
dealing with food so if you've got
somebody that's dealing with food that's
the way it can be passed and I won't go
through all of the ways where you can
find fecal coliforms you know if you go
to a restaurant quite often he'll find
fecal coliforms in the candy dish that's
right next to the register there's a lot
of different areas where you can
actually find these pathogens certainly
in daycares with all the diapers around
there that can be an issue when we start
looking at food exposures we can get
meat that's contaminated during
processing and just to kind of spend a
quick minute on that what you normally
see is a sugar toxin is usually not in
steak and the reason for that is when
you have a steak if if a cow has a coli
o157 in their gut if it gets on their
hide during the processing with a steak
you normally cook it and you cook the
outsides and that's where the pathogen
is and it's killed off fairly readily
however when you've got something like a
hamburger you take what's on the outside
grind it up and it's now on the inside
and once it's on the inside and you
don't cook your burger straight through
that's where a lot of these outbreaks
can happen well then when we go to
environmental exposures we do have
things like water parks we've had
outbreaks and we can go to places like
petting zoos where some of the animals
can have it the kids can pet the animals
and then if they don't wash their hands
it can contaminate themselves so there's
a lot of different areas that they can
get that so here's a few things out
there and I'll kind of hit a few of
these I talked about the burger that's
why if you go to mo nearly all fast-food
restaurants have a very strong protocol
these days for cooking their meat so we
really have not seen a lot of outbreaks
in a lot of the in food these days
because of some of the procedures
they've put in place I've mentioned
those cows but again one of the issues
out there is
you know when you're out in a cow
pasture and they've got you : one five
seven or any other sugar toxin-producing
e.coli you know the cows defecate in the
pasture and there's often runoff and so
you find cases where you'll have things
like apple cider so the cow pasture runs
off it gets onto the apples and we get
when you don't pasteurize that cider and
again cider has a nice acidity which
kills off a lot of the bacteria e.coli
o157 is one of those that are resistant
to those low PHS therefore you can have
outbreaks and apple cider we've had the
unpasteurized milk again by having run
off from other animals you can and get
other foods and then you've got that
nice little day care as well
unfortunately so I took one of the
publications and you can see the
publication down below but they're
saying all right when we finally find
e.coli o157 and in the latest
publication that was able to find on
this we talked about that water we
talked about the farm environments beef
again being one of the more significant
ones other meats as well but you've got
that Gary in that produce so a lot of
foods aren't safe because of that runoff
oh I'm sorry I've covered that slide
already so going into a few the outbreak
so we've had out there back in June 2014
there was a case of e.coli o157 87 the
one the big bad one that we worry about
in ground beef so that's fairly standard
what happened in this particular case
was they had 12 cases seven of them were
hospitalized it did span four states
because of course a lot of these packing
plants do distribute all over the
country the good news on that one is
there were zero deaths but what they
found is that at the particular packing
plant they did have contaminated ground
beef and that unfortunately with that
ground beef it was distributed to many
restaurants and retail areas throughout
the country one of the actions however
is the recall happened after the expert
date but again we have to have recalls
even after the expert on things like
food
because quite often people do freezes so
people at that point had to check their
frozen need to make sure that they
didn't have this particular lot and get
rid of it if they did
now one in 2014 I Robin e.coli o157 this
is an e.coli 1:21 and this occurred in
raw clover sprouts so again we had about
19 19 cases almost half of them were
hospitalized again 0 desc
and what they had done is they had
actually linked this to evergreen fresh
sprouts this was a place in Idaho that
had these contaminated raw clover
sprouts and when they do the
epidemiology trying to figure out what
is the cause they did find that's four
out of five people that had these raw
clover sprouts the week before often at
these restaurants so that was what led
them to the this particular place so
when the FDA inspectors then did go in
they did see areas of unsanitary
conditions so they had metal contact
this was in contact with food and so
basically the particular company was
able to get rid of that seed law one in
2013 this is nikola i 121 in Farmer
expand frozen foods so again this is one
of these areas where 35 cases 9
hospitalizations in many states out
there zero deaths but one of the big
ones on this one was that a lot of these
were under the age of 21 and two of
these people did develop hemolytic
uremic syndrome and the big issue with
this is that it went into frozen mini
pizza slices and these are things that
kids love to have it's very very
convenient where you've got these little
pizza slices you heat them up and so
they had to have this recall with
farmers fruit products etc to get that
out so when we are looking at diagnostic
recommendations we're starting to look
at what the CDC really wants of us out
there so why should we test obviously
it's good to test for any pathogen so
you know how to deal with it but you
want to keep these people hydrated you
know if you want to give them IVs to get
the volume up
they have found that to be helpful but
one of the big things is you know you
don't need antibiotics for a viral
infection you also don't take
antibiotics for a sugar toxin producing
e-coli what they unfortunately found is
some antibiotics will actually increase
the risk of hemolytic uremic syndrome so
again you know here is this push you
know people come in I wanted anybody
that got one antibiotic here's one of
the really significant reasons why we're
saying no no you run the test and an
antibiotic is not going to do any good
and not only not going to do you any
good but potentially could do you harm
they've actually even found things like
some of these indeed are real agents may
also increase the risk of hemolytic
uremic syndrome so again it pushes
things toward understanding what the
pathogen is so why would you not take an
antibiotic when you have e.coli cells
they've got this toxin in them when you
give some of the antibiotics that can
actually lyse these cells you're
actually going to be putting more toxin
into the environment
so as these coli are in the guts they
bind to the microvilli and they may be
going up to the kidney by giving
potentially the wrong antibiotics you're
gonna be putting out more of this toxin
as it's going toward the kidney and
therefore having a more significant
illness so here's what it used to be
when the CDC and the Joint Commission
got together and said okay who's to be
tested you look at visible Diary visible
blood certainly that's very very
significant
unfortunately not all sugar toxin e.coli
producers do have visible blood so then
I said okay is screening the season was
also significant again we do see this
more in the summertime more in the fall
time when again people are out doing the
water parks and doing more of the
outdoor cooking exam not getting that
cooking straight through does causes but
unfortunately this is something here
around we saw just a minute ago the
cases of the you know the frozen food
slices where you know that could go on
for quite some time we do worry about
age the young and the old are more
to some of these risk conditions however
again diarrhea occurs in everybody so
everybody's going to be issue to this so
when you look at it all together when
you looked at the statistics at the
beginning diarrheal disease is quite
common throughout the entire United
States and is a significant worldwide
pathogen throughout the world so to
really look at when you're dealing with
one of the other big things is if you
start seeing cases and you do have a
diagnostic for sugar toxin producing you
can help start limiting that a potential
outbreak because once they know there's
an outbreak going on the CDC can come in
they can investigate and by identifying
what the source is they can then put out
these you know concerns to the markets
to potentially withdraw particular laws
or to the consumers to make sure that
they can check their Lots at home to
make sure that they don't have one of
these suspect cases so when you put it
all together they've now said basically
rather than look at those particular
screening they really want everybody
tested so when we look at the testing
out there we've got the o157
and we've got the non oh one five seven
again if you look at all the ones out
there eco violent five seven is the most
common strain that produces it there's
many many other strains that have that
Shigella toxin but this is the big bad
one now because of that some labs only
test for o157 but again we do see even
in the cases in 2014 some of these non
oh one five seven strains were the angel
aaja chol agent so you know there's
plenty of cases out there right now
where if you are just running a colon
five seven you will miss the outbreak
when you look at a 1 5 7 vs. non a 1 5 7
assays the o157 are specific just to
that strain again you will miss anything
else that can produce the toxin but it's
not that it's fairly inexpensive though
that's the good news when you plate
these out you put them on a plate called
silver toe McConkey
and that tends to be the most common out
there when you're talking about the
assays for toxin you're usually talking
about the rapid as the Eliza's they're
there as well and they will pick up
anything that produces a toxin so what
the CDC at this point now is saying
because of these is they do want all
stools tested coming in from the
community with diarrhea for shaker toxin
e.coli you can do concurrent testing you
can actually culture that stool for o157
and you can look both for that sugar
toxin as well and when you do find a
one57 the laboratories do like the
public health do like having those
isolates sent to them they like to do
the conformation testing the additional
characterization that is all quite
helpful and of course you want to report
those results promptly to the position
because that is going to direct their
therapy again a lot of these tests when
you have the answer you can direct that
there be much much better as far as that
rationale out there it's it's a bit
difficult talking about this in that a
lot of hospitals that do sugar toxin
don't see tons and tons of cases however
one the CDC has looked at this they've
said okay
it is about as common sugar toxin E coli
is about as common as things like
salmonella Campylobacter and since it is
about as common it should be one of the
ones that are tested as much as well
again early diagnosis does help with
that therapy getting them off the
antibiotics keeping those kids hydrated
all of those things help and again
trying to limit that outbreak so why
every community-acquired stool again
many of these infections can be missed
what's the selector strategies normally
you wouldn't test a form stool it's just
the the diarrhea stools some sugar toxin
again you don't have the invisible blood
difficult to recover if you do wait and
this close case with many many pathogens
the longer you wait the harder it is to
recover so if somebody's coming in with
suspected sugar toxin and you're waiting
several days to get it out that name
resolving or at least harder to get and
it does help again prevent transmission
to other people these are people that if
you do identify them and they have any
access to be able to spread it we really
want to help educate them and limit them
from doing that so if these people
coming in they have a sugar toxin
producing in coli and they work in a day
care facility is probably not the best
strategy for them to go right back to
the day care facility and even when the
e.coli does resolve when one that one
the they should go quite some time
really being vigilant washing their
hands to make sure that they keep that
up food service worker again it's it's
really you don't want to be working with
food after this and even when it's
resolved you still want to take that
extra time when you've got your coli
o157 cultures out there again we talked
about the so Berto macconkey agar plate
there are several companies that have
nice chrome agar plates as well where
when that u coli o157 is on that plate a
hub is at least three companies out
there that do it you'll see a nice color
change and so you'll be able to see that
color change and identify it that way
when you're dealing with snack the issue
is that these particular period don't
ferment sorbitol so you're gonna see
that white colony it's about 16 to 24
hours incubated for 37 degrees again you
look for that color the color snack
plates don't have that color whereas if
you're looking for the chroma markers
they'll have a particular color to them
at that point you've got the suspect
colonies and you're able to have a lot
of latex tests out there then actually
work quite well when you're dealing with
isolated colonies so you pick a few of
those colonies you can run the latex at
that point confirm that test when
dealing with the sugar toxin producing
e.coli again this detects all sugar
toxin producing cholera and just a one57
as a caution they have found some ecoli
that can produce sugar toxin but they
don't have the right genes to actually
bind and deliver the toxin to other
parts so with microbiology
there's no 100% answer for anything out
there so what do you test
look at that manufacturer's instructions
and you'll be able to see usually you
have two options out there there are
some tests that work for drug stool
either fresh or frozen and some work
much better on cultures and when you
have the culture it can be broth culture
or play culture so the issue is drug
stool obviously you'll get saying their
results cultures you're going to be
getting results in 24 hours now
surprisingly there's actually not a lot
of molecular options out there right now
but there are a lot of public health
laboratories that do use molecular ones
so and quite often they validated for
isolated colonies but a lot of people
really aren't doing that right from the
stool itself so when you're looking at
it unfortunately doing these e.coli
studies are not easy because it is more
seasonal because you don't know where
these outbreaks are going to strike
actually gathering the amount of data to
produce an actual study it is fairly
difficult so I don't want to look at all
the literature and trying to compare
things out there there's not really a
lot of literature to go to so when I
look out there there were a few
published studies from Alberta Canada
looked at the performance of rapid
assays versus in-house PCR and when they
looked at that in-house PCR they looked
at a few the particular ones out there
ie hack on the stack both of them did
use at this point the enrichment culture
and they also tested that stack on the
direct stool and some of these
sensitivities out there and the
predicted values are there so in that
particular study that sensitivity about
35% on the heck from the broad culture
leading to a positive predictive value
of about 54% when they use the
particular stack asset out there the
sensitivity was higher the predictive
value was better leading overall to
particular different sensitivities with
diff
predictive values on that broth culture
and again I won't talk to too much about
that majority the true positives weren't
detected in Forge lane they had more
than detected in that broth they did
unfortunately want to ask they have a
bit more false positives so usually at
least with a lot of these assays if you
rely on either sensitivity or
specificity it's a much better screen so
if you don't even have a high
sensitivity or a high specificity that
leads to some confusion out there on
what the next steps are so that was a
good thing about one of these particular
assays is with the higher specificity
the predict positive predictive value
wasn't better out there so when we're
looking at all this when we're trying to
start preventing sugar toxin-producing
e.coli i can't say enough the first
thing out there is hand-washing every
time after a person goes to the
restaurant unfortunately they're you
know they've done the studies and the
average person leaves about a tenth of a
gram behind so people aren't as
efficient out there of course that I can
lead to things like issues with
whirlpools if you've got six people in
the world pool and everybody leaves a
tenth of a gram of feces behind and
you've got multiple people getting in
and out quite often you better make sure
that water is chlorinated again the same
thing with water parks you have a lot of
kids out there that can have a diaper
and obviously they have an accident in
that diaper and they can be in that
water and if you know water parks don't
have that water chlorinated they can be
a source you got to make sure that you
do a prior to preparing foods contact
with animals again if you're at a place
that you're dealing with animals
especially with children wash your hands
afterwards when you're looking at that
food you really do want to make sure
that it is prepared appropriately again
the big one up there is things like
ground beef if you like your steak rare
that's okay because it's a steak and
again you're cooking the outside when
you're doing talking with a burger it is
a bit more important to
but through cutting boards are big went
out there for Microbiology it happens
over and over again and unfortunately it
happens in a lot of restaurants where if
they've got some contaminated meat they
can be working with that contaminated
meat and then stop making salads and
cutting salads right on that same board
that becomes a significant issue and
that can be the source these cutting
boards are something that has been the
source out there for quite some time so
you got to make sure that when you're
out there cleaning those cutting boards
if you if you're in a restaurant having
dedicated to state versus other
vegetables because again you're not
going to be you know heating those
vegetables afterwards they're they're
not going to be because they're not
gonna be cooked afterwards they can be
that source and I know a lot of people
out there love things like raw milk and
other things but pasteurization does
help when you're dealing with raw milk
if you do pasteurize it's you don't have
to worry about e.coli o157 so that is a
help so looking at all that it is more
significant so it's going to try to wrap
it up to get ten minutes more for
discussion when we're talking about
these sugar talks producing e coli they
certainly are a significant health
threat diagnostic testing does help and
again the big thing about that is a can
direct therapy so you've got the case
right now where if you've got something
and you can produce something same day
that does quite often help parents come
in and they demand antibiotics and if
you're able to at least run some
preliminary tests upfront to say it may
actually be a sugar toxin producing e
coli I am NOT giving you the end of our
extra reasons X&Y that will make the
parents stop if you don't have those
answers quite often the doctors go the
other way
give the antibiotics or the patient's
demand them so having answers either
same day or 24 hours later do help and I
know a lot of people out there that run
both because especially when you've got
a bloody stool this is
you really worry about and when you put
this all together and appropriate
therapy does reduce these complications
such as hemolytic uremic syndrome and
thrombotic thrombocytopenic purpura
which i'm glad i pronounced right
because it is not the most easiest term
so with that i was going to turn it over
to any questions out there well thank
you dr. Moore for that informative
presentation I'm thrilled to be part of
the Cardinal Health lab exchange before
we begin the Q&A session I'd like to
remind our audience that you can submit
your questions by typing them into the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button on the lower
left of the presentation window so let's
just wait a minute to see if there are
any questions if there are no questions
at this time I'd like to thank our
sponsor or lettering for making today's
educational webinar possible please make
sure to head to the community of
learning following this presentation to
have the opportunity to engage in live
chat with dr. Moore and your peers and
have any questions that you may have
answered about she can talk she could
toxin-producing e.coli what you need to
know now as a reminder I'd like everyone
to remember that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
October of this year you will receive an
email from lab roots informing you when
this presentation is available we invite
you to afford that announcement to any
of your colleagues we're not able to
glitch in today's presentation thank you
all very much for joining us today we
look forward to seeing you again next
time until then thank you again and
goodbye